Boo Boo do
ex 4 sr Seed sky green
n one reason Fuga 4 play nbd Pop-up is
nars Fiber beads
wh It
took 1 year and 3 months before the wasabi sounds, but the
wasabi grows even if there is too much sunlight  It doesn't grow up without anything, but the
most important thing in making it cold is the
reason water. 13 It
's said that it's 18 degrees in the city
.  Life
[Music]
Suppose you plant wasabi once and it gets worse. The wasabi cannot be harvested for another year and a half, so except for bandar service farms services are you do, the
working needs are currently 19m.
We are harvesting 300,000 to 400,000 wasabi with wasabi.
It is a mechanized work such as rice cultivation, which is called midday making work. It
is different from the action.
The part of the sun that you smoke and eat is a place that can be used as a stalk and a sound depending on the part of the sun,
so it is now called the longitude, but it is not a sound at all. It is
also a part
of the time.
There are various spicy plants that can produce
this kind of entanglement, but I think that this isabi that comes out of this refreshing nose is good for wasabi, but the
deep taste that you can feel the umami that remains after that is still attractive.
I've heard that it has been yellow since the Edo period,
so the wind has changed, but in the
work era, I've been doing the work that I've inherited from the old days, and I've
been doing it forever.
I'm leaving, after all I
want to make my lion for the
rest of the future Yeah
tan